so there's a really good example you
could take with anything that happens in
the gun industry or or the gun culture
or it's like oh well that guy got hit
and so no everyone just like leaves him
alone for a while he'll figure it out
and what i'm saying is that
i think you're identifying that
in many ways this the left circles the
wagons
and they protect their own and there's
there's a lot of things that you can go
through real quickly so i'll just launch
them one at a time um it was zooby who
said
um and uh calling someone hypocrite only
matters if they have integrity i'm
paraphrasing import poorly but like okay
we know that doesn't work the splc
is not an honest organization okay we
know that so then they're not credible
we don't use them because they're
credible but somebody else will because
it's advantageous do you fight fire with
fire sometimes sometimes however what i
think a more critical condition is why
does the conservative party not use the
department of justice to actually do
justice and i don't mean this in the
well actually mentality right but it's
you look at all the all the the these
criticisms across the uh
the 529
issue you look at are the the 529
insurrection you look at the the things
that happen in minneapolis the things
that happened in kenosha it's why don't
you actually just i don't know maybe do
your job right so
because if you're not doing justice
you're not the department of justice and
if you're not doing justice as the
department of justice you should find a
new job
yeah you should be removed and and you
don't you do i do not think you win in
the game of attrition with people who
are already committed to a zealous
ideology that will never stop maybe
abolishing these corrupted institutions
might be something better instead of
them being weaponized against the
political parties because when another
political party goes into power they're
going to be using the same tools that
they use on the other party well here
perspective perfect example would be
what was her name what the
the view the gal from the view who said
that uh gun gun laws in america would
change if black joy behar right yes if
black people had them right okay do you
censor her do you cut her from the film
or do you cut her from no you ignore her
so she's she's not a serious she's not a
serious speaker and and as that
continues you encourage over the long
tail decision to build your community to
build your friends to focus if you want
to defeat ignorant people you isolate
them from the halls of intelligence she
wasn't wrong though joy behar
what she's saying she's not talking
about conservatives these so joy behar
on the view says that when black people
get guns the gun laws will change
now we as people who don't like racism
or who uh like guns we hear that and
we're like that's ridiculous like we
would ever support that race no no it's
these uppity liberals of course want
more gun control and especially if
minorities they don't like are getting
this look what happened with the black
panthers exactly that was california
that was san francisco absolutely it was
california and san francisco in a
different time i don't want to go down
that road too far what i do want to go
down to is the point of white fragility
what did we learn from the book white
fragility the author is a terrible
person and she wants to project that on
everybody else and she's racist she's a
racist who wants to project her racism
on everybody else so a an honest
academic would look at that and say
force we need to have an honest kind of
a conversation about this i see i i see
people on the right internalize what joy
behar said and um when you internalize
that pain you assume they're talking
about you when they're actually talking
about themselves so when they project
when they say these things i just always
assume they're talking about themselves
you know why
people
have a worldly have have their worldview
and they assume i i should say low low
iq people assume everyone else must see
the world the same way they do therefore
if they don't agree with me it's because
they're lying so someone like joy behar
when she says that she's actually
talking more about herself and what she
feels than what anyone else actually
thinks
i don't think she's i don't think she
has a low iq i think she's just mean
i i think it's i think it's i think it's
fueled from spite it's just rage but why
would you say why would you say that
about anybody why would you say that
about anybody is that the sole thing
that motivates them is racism because
she's a racist exactly so she needs to
spend some time figuring out who she is
she sees the world through this lens and
assumes
that's why people would do something she
does not understand the fact that you
know we're all i don't know are you
you're familiar with major terrain yes
yeah we're we're fans of black guns
matter and maj toure and the work he
does and uh
it's like she doesn't even know he
exists i mean literally she probably
doesn't i think that she sees this world
then she says everyone else must think
the same way as me but i'm a good person
because i don't act on it we're all like
no we don't think that we think you're a
racist this this is just a a modernized
version of white man's burden right
that's all this is i look uh it's hard
for me to be this good white person you
know it's my burden
to have to go around and say this stuff
i'm just trying to speak spent uh uh
sense to you folks are you talking about
like the 1800s white man's birth yeah
it's the same thing yeah the part where
like we have
things like travel and medicine and
written language we should spread that
around the world yeah but they've taken
it they've taken that and just injected
it into everything yeah they call it
they call it white savior complex right
it's the same thing it's the same thing
they think they know better for you
that's the whole like remember that guy
in uh california where he was cheering
on the rioting and then he's like you
see his twitter thread where he's like
yes yes do it yeah wait a minute why are
you coming to my neighborhood don't come
to my name go downtown and it's like he
actually i think didn't he actually say
like go downtown where the movie where
the poor people lived and he was mad
they're going to beverly hills i'm like
bro they're coming to eat the rich
you're not safe they've been saying this
for a while i mean yeah they don't say
eat the rich because they're hungry they
say eat the rich because they're greedy
yeah so exactly i'm still working this
idea out i don't claim to know the
answer here i don't know the solutions
but i think maybe it would be more
advantageous to stop relying on
corrupted institutions to do the right
thing and i think uh moving away from
them defunding them abolishing them i
think would be a better strategy than
saying hey bill barr mr c.i.a do the
right thing here um i i i think it would
be better to to you know
i don't know some people say play fire
with fire and i understand that argument
i understand where you guys are coming
from uh but but my knee-jerk reaction is
like wait what we're doing here is we're
adding more fuel to the fire and it's
already very hot in this room well
that's my point of view so i think
you're and i might be wrong and i might
be wrong well you might be and let me
tell you why
i think you're seizing a lot on the
argument of state intervention and just
setting that aside for a moment because
i don't even know i don't think we agree
entirely there but
when he mentioned something like having
our own version of the splc obviously
we're not saying we should have an
organization that lies but the point is
the left has re-engineered the culture
such that being accused of having any
kind of conservative value comes with a
very swift and significant social cost
but they target attack and harass
individuals and i
think that it is a very good idea for
conservatives to push for a culture
where there is a social cost to being a
communist right if you are going to go
out there and say i support the ideology
which has resulted in hundreds of
millions of innocent people being
slaughtered
folks should probably not want to
associate with if you want if you want
to advocate for the abolition of private
property start with yourself if you're
not willing to do that you don't believe
it but that that is an old tale that
what you're dealing with is an asymmetry
of ideas
an asymmetry in the side of warfare you
look at after nuclear after nuclear
weapons were created the idea of warfare
had to change you can't put the genie
back in the bottle after the machine gun
horse charges didn't matter anymore
after bomber planes large formations of
people don't work anymore armored
standard armor didn't matter when
gunpowder became ubiquitous it took time
but if then eventually gunpowder
defeated armor so you're then armor
became massive tanks which then are def
you know right now we have drones you
having a tank of battalion is
functionally useless against a powerful
western military what happened after
this history lesson at we saw in well
not history i don't need to talk down
that's not the right way of saying it um
but after world war ii what were the
next major conflicts korea my
grandfather was a pow for three years so
i heard a lot of stories um and then so
there was that and then there was
vietnam and you saw the rise of
insurgency warfare insurgency has become
such a buzzword amongst the military
elite that it's like i'm cool i said
insurgency metaphysics polymath banana
peel but whatever um so the point being
said though is how does an asymmetry
work the the left has functionally and
fully adopted asymmetrical warfare from
the side of what we know we had called
terrorism but an insurgency it is a
situation where i get to harm you
but if you do what i do to you if you if
you reciprocate that's bad so you see
this within the in the the conflict the
the riots in minneapolis the riots were
a really good example the
antifa or the rioters will provoke a
response and use that response as
justification for further
further evidence of their need for
revolution who's been calling for a
revolution this entire time
it hasn't been the right yeah right well
look or not
understanding insurgency conflict how to
fight against a counter insurgency the
purpose of an insurgency is not to
defeat you in a military battle it's to
break your will to the system how do
americans under how do how does the
right or how do americans defeat this
social contagion that is this insurgency
which is both bred on on
our soil and abroad
is you remember the foundations that
built our country it's almost the lord
of the rings plot all over again you
have to understand who you are and where
you come from and then live up to those
virtues that is very important that you
mention that because one of the huge
problems right now is that conservatives
but i would say americans overall and
people living in western societies have
no idea
what their values are or what values
upon which their society has been
founded and so when the left comes along
and they try to deconstruct a lot of
people are completely helpless they
don't know how to defend and justify the
values that our society promotes they're
incapable of doing it i think you're
right that we need to know what we
believe and we don't yeah i don't i
think this is where we kind of differ
because i don't see the left as the main
problem here i see a divide and conquer
agenda i see voting for the lesser of
two evils that is continuing to plague
this country i see a duopoly i see fifth
generational warfare being raged on the
american people and i think the people
that are in power are using the left
right now because they're the most
easily to get used now they're the most
easily to push this agenda through
because it's convenient now but as soon
as it becomes unconvenient for the
larger agenda for the larger fifth
genera fifth generation warfare
enslavement of humanity they're going to
be using a right wing element of it
that's also going to be pushing on a
different front that's going to be
taking away our rights and our economic
abilities uh to to survive and prosper
so more hold on how do you how do you
you have sorry i i just want to say this
one thing and then i'll let you jump in
so more than one thing can be true at a
time it can absolutely be the case that
the ruling elites see the left is
convenient revolutionaries to destroy
the existing social order and then bring
to fruition whatever it is that they're
seeking to transform our society into it
is also the case that the strategy by
which they do that is to have the left
completely erode any and all moral
surrounding family values destroy the
family and then the government comes
into that vacuum and usurps the
responsibility that the family normally
has and they do this with the
participation right what we have to do
oh i totally agree with you on that but
that's part of why we do have to fight
left-wing ideology and and defend and
fight for the family so i don't think
it's enough to say the left is being
used by these tyrants therefore we just
look at the tyrants we actually have to
fight the ideology itself because it's
useful to them for a reason so my
opinion is i think we're in such a
desperate situation we should be
fighting against the enslavement the
evisceration of our rights and the
destruction of our financial futures
whether you're on the left right or
center i think it's it's time more than
ever to let go of
of these kind of differences and say hey
we're actually being really hurt here
we're actually being really screwed over
here and unless we we come together
unless we realize that we're all in this
boat together we're all going down as a
sinking ship so like i don't want the
people who grew children oh look look i
hear what you're saying but i don't
think you understand the deep
ideological divide between in the united
states from left and right
you have people who have no moral
framework they they they they will say
simultaneously stop and frisk is bad and
red flag laws are good even though
they're variants of the exact same thing
and one's even worse red flag laws stop
and frisk on steroids they're forward
why no moral framework so when you go to
them and say hey you know we need to
come together because all these bad
things are happening they'll go oh
you're right of course and as soon as
you turn around they'll they'll hit you
in the back yeah i'm not saying it's a
good strategy i'm not saying it's even
going to work
it doesn't it doesn't work okay well
it's it's it's um isaiah 5 20. they will
call good evil and evil good you cannot
have
you cannot have you cannot break bread
and have commonality with somebody who
calls what you call good evil so problem
that you have do we focus on the left do
we focus on the globalist do we focus on
all these you know what they all saw the
the point that you're saying they solved
the same question but but you can't you
can't you can't just advocate for the
family you have to have the one fourth
you have to build first i'm gonna i'm
gonna i'm gonna agree with luke on this
one i think if we just compromise with
the child drag shows then maybe no no no
no no
the right-wing political establishment
willingly going along with this and
pretending that they're like they're
going to be helping us when they're not
i that's what i think there's a mistake
too i think there's a i think there's a
divide first of all of our understanding
of right wing and like republicans right
the republicans in dc and then the
republicans across the nation are two
totally different things right for
example you're talking about why didn't
the fbi or the cia move on 529 right
insurrection the insurrection who was
the president at the time donald trump
that was his fbi that was his cia why
didn't they move right and then you're
definitely not going to get a move out
of the out of a biden fbi or doj the the
problem is so entrenched in dc right the
the fbi is is a bunch of it used to be a
republican stronghold but republicans
for of dc right you're james comey's of
the world bill barr uh robert mueller
right
this is the uniparty right there there
is one belief in the dc realm right it
one when you're outside you know in west
virginia new york or whatever uh and
you're it's left versus right democrat
versus republican but when you once you
get to dc once you win that battle and
you get to dc the fight becomes the
incumbents versus everybody else so the
problem you have is that the
when you try to abolish the fbi or you
try to abolish these corruptions
i'm with you on that right but first you
have to get in the guys who believe that
into those positions because you can't
abolish that institution while you have
james comey or a bill bar or robert
mueller there in fact i wanted to the
the whole mueller investigation and that
you know james comey gets fired then the
special uh council gets appointed for
and robert mueller gets selected as as a
special counsel if a couple of things
were adjusted slightly differently what
you would have actually had end up with
is that there's a universe somewhere out
there where
bill barr would have been selected the
special counsel and then donald trump
would have hired robert mueller to head
the fbi it would it's that you got
you're dealing with the same pool of
talent no matter what right that's the
problem the pool of talent you could
draw on to put into the institutions
that and so then it goes back to what
you're saying build the family build the
community right because first you have
to build the community then you go and
take the halls of power and then you put
the community in that hall of power and
then you do what you want
that's the problem but just for the
record i i don't stand by any groomers i
don't think you should be working or
lying with any type of people who are
hurting children
but the one point i want to make here is
that it's both republicans and democrats
that are going to jeffrey epstein's
island
i need to address that point you're
making because when you say you go to
them and say we're being really hurt by
this you're talking about people who
overtly and and uh
with pride particularly to clarify those
people i i'm saying absolutely not you
cannot support people who hurt small
children especially with how evil
they're doing it especially with the
damages that they're causing them so
what i'm saying is that the conversation
should be what i'm saying is the
conversation should be a little bit more
nuanced rather than generalized that's
just the perspective that i'm trying to
input so so here's what i would
recommend go to someone you see as a
democrat voter or someone's perceived as
a left and say do you agree with sex
changes for children do you agree with
child drag shows if they say no okay
let's have a conversation if they say
yes which 95 percent probably will maybe
you don't need five percent
then you can be like okay have a nice
day
what you're asking about tim is the same
thing that comes into the gun control
conversation as was the last time you
had an honest conversation about this
about gun control as as a whole like
okay
my i was politically introduced into the
gun control conversation what
conversation okay that's such a
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 p.m
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you